I have it all planned out.
Pray tell.
I'm getting...
two orders of bread sticks.
Two.
Those things
knock your socks off.
Enzo puts
some spice on 'em.
I don't know what it is,
but it's good
and you dip it in olive oil.
Forget about it.
And I'm wavering
on the main course
between the veal
and the lasagne.
But I think I gotta go
with lasagne, right?
Wait... So you--
you've been dreaming
about breadsticks
and lasagne.
I've been on a diet
of watery soup,
mouldy bread and maggots.
So yeah, I've been dreaming
about breadsticks
and lasagne.
I mean, sue me.
Should I have been dreaming
about something else?
You tell me.
Well.
There's wine.
Oh, well wine's good.
I was thinking
about a nice Chi-anti.
-Chianti
-Chianti. Right.
-And then there's dessert .
-You gotta have dessert.
Gotta have dessert.
And after that?
I don't know.
Use your imagination.
Who needs imagination?
Whoa.
-Oh.
-Damn it.